hi this is pressure Locker in this video
we're going to count to infinity and
beyond and we're going to learn about a
special class of numbers called
transfinite ordinals which can arise in
infinite chess but to get started we're
going to consider a puzzle from a
regular game of chess here's a position
on the board and it's White's turn to
move and white needs to be able to
checkmate black in two moves this is a
typical type of chess puzzle and the way
you work it out is you consider all the
ways that white could move and all the
ways that black could counter respond in
the best possible way when the puzzle
says that white can mate in two that
means there's a strategy that white can
force black to make moves and white can
still win within two moves so in this
position it looks like white is that as
a great disadvantage because black has a
couple of ponds and all everything is
protected however white can utilize its
knight to force black into a bad
position if the knight goes to e6
it checks the black King and there are
only two positions the King can go it
can either go to the corner or it can
try and evade one more to h7 but no
matter what the King does White's rook
can respond by going to that column and
it's a checkmate the King has nowhere to
go the knight is blocking the two exits
and the entire column is blocked by the
rook
so this is an example of a chess puzzle
and how white can win in two moves so
now let's do a more complicated puzzle
this is a puzzle where white has a turn
to move and can mate in five moves here
white looks to be at a great
disadvantage its King is out in the open
it only has a knight and a queen whereas
black has two rooks a queen and a
somewhat defended King and two pawns
so how is white going to be able to
force a mate in exactly five moves Y can
get started by putting a check on the
king now the king could make a stupid
move by moving to f8 but if the king
moved over there then white would
obviously have a checkmate right here at
f7 so in these types of puzzles we're
going to assume that black and white are
making the best possible moves so we
want to avoid these kinds of stupid
moves where it would result in an early
checkmate for black so we're going to
assume black is not going to make that
bad decision of going to f8 and instead
black is going to go to the corner and
evade the checkmate White's Knight can
respond by putting a check on f7
at this position black only has one way
to go it needs to move the King and it
needs to move it back to g8
now white can move its knight and reveal
a check and also give a double check so
this puts the black King once again in a
bind and the only way to get out of it
is to move back to the corner and now
comes the brilliant move in this
sequence white is going to sacrifice its
queen and smother the king in this
position the King can't take the Queen
because it's being protected by the
knight so the only way that black can
get out of this is by killing the Queen
with its rook and that is the trap that
white is set up because now the knight
can go to f7 and that's a checkmate so
this is known as a smother checkmate and
this is an example of how white can
finish off the checkmate and five moves
so we're going to take this puzzle and
mathematically define a few concepts so
in this final position where white has
checkmated black we're going to define
this as a position of the board that has
value 0 White has already won the game
and so it has a value of 0
we are then going to define that a
position on the board has value alpha
plus 1
I've white can move to a position that
has value alpha so right now we have a
value of zero so if we go back one move
that would be a move that a position of
the board which has value 1 because from
here white can move to a checkmate which
is a value of zero if we go back one
more move of black and white this is a
position where white can force a
checkmate in exactly two moves so we
would say this position of the board has
a value of two and we could go back in
that same puzzle to all the way to a
value of five but basically intuitively
a position of the board has value alpha
if white can force a checkmate in
exactly alpha moves one thing I'll say
is that we don't know what the value of
the starting position of the game of
chess is we don't know if it's a
guaranteed win for white if it's going
to be a draw or guaranteed win for black
so some positions we may not have
actually calculated it because there's
so many chess positions that are
possible but in puzzles where we know
white can guarantee a mate or black can
guarantee a mate we can determine what
the value of those positions are so
we've demonstrated chess board positions
which have finite values going up to
five and of course you can demonstrate
them for higher values but there are
actually some interesting values that
you can get on the chess board in a
special game of chess so before I get to
that I want to talk about the transplant
ordinals so let's imagine counting to
infinity and beyond
so the counting numbers have a very
specific order we know that 1 comes
after 0 2 comes after 1 3 comes after
two and so on so every single number in
the counting numbers has a specific
ordering and we know that something
comes after it so in set theory you can
actually do
find something very interesting which is
you can define something which comes
after all of this so this would be a
limit ordinal called Omega and this is a
trance the first transfinite ordinal so
it's a very specific and kind of
complicated way to define it I'm going
to gloss over the details for this but
basically you can have a number which
comes after all the counting numbers
from there you can actually say alright
let's add one to that number and we have
Omega plus 1 we can apply the successor
relationship which is well defined in
this operation and you can count to
Omega plus two you can continue counting
all the way up to Omega plus Omega which
will end up being the number Omega times
two and we might as well just keep going
we can go to Omega times two plus one
and if we keep adding we'll eventually
end up at Omega times Omega which will
denote as Omega squared and naturally we
keep on counting we'll end up to a point
where we're multiplying Omega times
itself Omega times which will be Omega
to the power of Omega so we've counted
some really huge numbers here but just
keep in mind these are actually all very
special kinds of sets so they're what's
known as countably infinite sets and
this is all they're all well ordered
sets and there's some very interesting
theorems that we call these the ordinals
because these are every other type of
way we can have well ordered sets will
actually be isomorphic to one of these
and if you keep on counting you can
actually get to the uncountable
transfinite ordinals which is a whole
separate topic but for now let's just
deal with some of these countably
infinite or transplendent or ttles so
what's the point of all of this
well these kinds of numbers actually
come up in combinatorial game theory and
using a special game of chess and some
of the puzzles we've gone through we're
going to demonstrate a game which has an
interesting value of Omega so let's
consider this puzzle and I've provided a
reference for the paper where this comes
from so this is kind of a special game
of chess you know this isn't a real
board
white doesn't have a king on it and you
know Black has three rooks but still the
point of the game is that black wants to
avoid being checkmated and white wants
to checkmate black so we can analyze
this game that supposed lack is to play
here and black wants to avoid being
checkmated white wants to get to a
checkmate what is the best possible way
that both players can play so this is
the kind this is like a chess puzzle
that we've been solving but it's a
different configuration there's no white
King so obviously there's no way that
black can create a checkmate so the only
thing black can try and do is avoid the
checkmate and white is going to try and
checkmate so if you go and analyze this
position there are a lot of different
ways you can go through but there's
actually only one thing that can happen
here black can try and avoid a checkmate
by moving the rook up and white is
actually going to have a mating net
where it moves with the rook and the
Queen this is a very famous mating
pattern and so the black king moves out
of the way and once the White Queen
moves up there's nowhere that the black
king can go this is checkmate
so we could say the starting value of
this fictitious board would have had a
value of two because white was able to
checkmate black in two moves so now
let's continue this example let's
imagine we started everything just one
position down so once again there's
really nothing else for black to do
except move its rook two positions off
so now this creates one extra spot where
blacks King can evade so when white
applies the same weight mating net
procedure is going to result in a
checkmate but it's going to result in a
checkmate in one more move than before
so the starting value the position of
this board actually had a value of three
so now we can generalize this let's
imagine we're playing the same game
but instead of just being limited to the
regular chessboard let's imagine it's an
infinite board so it goes infinitely
high up so instead of stopping at eight
it continues infinitely high up and it
continues infinitely high on both sides
so the rook could actually move
infinitely high up this will create an
infinite number of spaces where the
black King can evade the mating net
procedure so eventually we know that
white is going to win this game it's a
guaranteed win for white and it's white
is going to do the same mating procedure
but there's no like trap right here so
this black King and actually just
continue to move up eventually black is
going to lose this but what's the value
of this game we know it's a win for
white but it has to be bigger than every
counting number that we know so the
answer is this game has a starting value
of Omega because this is going to be the
first number that's larger than all of
the counting numbers so we've
demonstrated a game which actually has a
value of a transfinite ordinal so these
trans fightin ordinals we think they're
just interesting consoles we actually we
can demonstrate in combinatorial game
theory they have an application that
this infinite game of chess has a value
of Omega there are other complicated
games I've provided you should check out
this paper if you're interested in
learning more about it there's a lot of
interesting details they've actually
come up with some games which have
values like Omega squared and Omega to
the fourth so it's really neat that
these transplanted Orioles have found a
use that you can rise in the game of
infinite chess so I hope you appreciate
that you've learned a new you know a
different set of numbers and you've also
learned about the game of infinite chess
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Walker and if you like this
video please check out my books I
provided links in the video description